in other news a jury in chicago has
found jesse smallett guilty of staging a
racist anti-gay attack on himself and
then lying to police about it the former
empire actor was convicted on five of
the six charges connected to this highly
publicized incident he now faces up to
three years in prison charlie demar has
been covering the trial for us
jessie smallett said nothing moments
after jurors found him guilty on five of
the six counts of disorderly conduct
after deliberating for just over nine
hours he was found not guilty on count
six which involved a later report to
police they found mr smallett guilty of
virtually all charges of doing exactly
what we said he did
the five counts stem from smilet telling
police in january 2019 that he'd been
attacked by two men
beat him up doused him in bleach and put
a rope around his neck initially
identified by smilet as his attackers
brothers abel and ola osindaro both
testified last week that smullett
orchestrated the hoax and paid them 3
500 dollars to stage the attack smolette
himself took the stand maintaining his
innocence and that there was no hoax mr
smallett would not have lost this case
as he did today unless the jury found
that he lied to them but smilet was
found not guilty on count six reporting
in february the following month to a
detective that he'd been the victim of
an aggravated battery you cannot say
jesse is lying and just is not lying for
the same exact
incident so we feel 100 percent
confident
that this case will be
won on appeal attorney joe tamborino
says the jury might have felt they had
already convicted smilet on enough
counts they could have decided that
perhaps the sixth count maybe they found
that with that one particular officer
there really wasn't a lie
smellette says the actor is smut's
attorney rather says the actor is
committed to clearing his name the judge
set a post-trial hearing for the end of
january and
the sentencing date has yet to be set
nate
charlie thank you